[Musique]
vois personnellement j'imagine et paris
cette école en paradis ils ont quitté
leur pays le congo brazzaville pour
conquérir paris mec de l'élégance quant
aux mannequins dont ouvriers parfois
chômeurs joba l'arrêt docteur liman se
présente avant tout comme les rois de la
sape
olala c'est la classe
de fond derrière ça c'est pas mal ça
fait sanguins pour
moi la vie feuillard gagnait plus que la
veille
quand vous achetez quelque chose qui
n'est pas eu d'effets ça n'appelle
valeur d'une serre outils
made un détail
moi ça me plaît d'être bien sapés parce
que je me sens
je me sens capable je me sens énorme
là je cause avec un personnage et il va
prendre pour un
c'est ça les vacances la photo soit
l'âge peut pas trop risqué bien qu'on me
suis aussi très bien qu sentais bien à
l'aise
comme les années 60 dans les années 60
georges admis là je fais ça ça fait un
peu de pluie
mais c'est pas depuis l'usiné ça c'est
nous même et depuis des mois c'est pour
nous ouais faut pas que la ja et
si ça fait ch ou non de mon mât de l'été
comme ça c'est bien et alors qu'ils
rentrent bien là tu viens à l'aise là je
me sens vraiment très bien même
je vais faire la cravate à la manière de
giscard
amy chua limite souvent le président des
présidents le président mitterrand
carter grand-père l'année
comment il s'appelle reagan nous prenez
que les présidentes j'ai eu l'impression
d'un jour parce que l'exemple du
président quand la présence à l'ag vie
le président giscard d'estaing je sais
pas en quelle année à kinshasa mais j'ai
tant qu' à kinshasa il était habillé on
en gabardine
[Musique]
gris pétrole
m et la gabardine du jamais vu quoi ça
c'est ça c'est pour assurer que les
gonzes ça c'est ton bhl avec noblesse il
est à remarquer tout de suite le nouëne
j'ai remarqué tous le nez puis la
chaussure qu'il avait dû weston ont
triplé semaine à l'ariana remarqué que
quand le besoin les présidents le
contenu des présents également j'ai
remarqué plus le noeud l'élégance de
giscard ce qu'ils disent qu'il suit non
l'apogée de chou il parle mais chez les
vertueuses et l'élégance ici quand ils
voient comme le président est allé comme
les journalistes l'analyste la livre mon
souci
[Musique]
qu'est ce qui compte le plus les femmes
la sape pour moi annoncé la salle
ça une seule femme ça va mais là ça peut
ne pas voir romain quinze ou vingt ou
trente ou cinquante falise donc
c'est ça quand quoi où est-ce qu'on se
sape pour les femmes ah non moi j'ai
sympa pour les femmes l'âge et sap pour
mon corps je fais vivre mon corps à moi
parce qu'on n'est que des passagers sur
cette terre donc je fais vivre mon corps
à moi tant que je vis j'ai fait vivre
mon corps
[Musique]
ils partagent une petite chambre sixième
étage d'un immeuble bourgeois quant aux
dépenses alimentaires elle dépasse
rarement les 800 francs par mois
[Musique]
et
aujourd'hui c'est mon jour monsieur
c'est aussi une belle journée
aujourd'hui oui sûrement d'avoir de
belles chaussures et sociale cds rahama
oui oui c'est du cap ont bien poussé
offensive survient six mois ce concert
ils sont venus ce mois m'appelle
médecins des pieds a très souvent et
c'est du gros coup ça se trouve où
convergent les gens n'ont pas le trac je
suis fait ça toi problème
ca c
le grand capot est en cours
le smic est ce une annonce en coûte même
pas les accès le double non pas le
double de quoi triple même ah
bon on va voir ça bon comme tu sais le
président de la cua de warwick sa foi ne
réussit pas de cas pour bien convenir à
le voir
des films et des photos bien su le faire
oui tu te rappelles mais c'est là on
l'avait su que le présent des capots
bien cool quand tu fais le mariage avec
capobianco l'appui d'un mariage est
considéré dès lundi a pas de cas pour
bien qu'il ya des moins weston ça peut
aller mais d'autres paires de chaussures
- west show ça peut aller quand vous
bien coché le concours ayant causé le
comprennent la paire la plus chère du
monde la terre la plus chère au monde
chez le capot bien qu les chefs de blanc
ça peut qu'apprendre retour normalement
fait bien sapés de laure et tourcoing
faut être bien sapés parce qu'on va te
voir votre a quitté la france vous
présentez vos preuves
une image que tu rêvais de la france
normalement alors tu présentes tout
jusqu'à la france est à tous alors se
promener là si on a l'argent faucon
satrape toujours y avait une différence
en différents chalets et rester et nous
toi mon cas on le connaissait bon l'a
déjà vu au rex douce et de la lehman et
djaballah
ouais ouais nous souhaitons lui il est
connu sous le nom de pétrole et du congo
[Musique]
joba la docteure l'imam et d'autres
compatriotes présente régulièrement leur
garde-robe personnel dans les concours
d'élégance du rex
[Musique]
bon
toi ça dépend en fait ça dépend nous par
exemple moi j'achète des fringues ici en
france j'en vois au pays mamans élevant
au vent le double elle me fait un mandat
par exemple de 20 me font avec sue avec
vingt huit ans je peux enlever au moins
800 pour mes fringues et moi même et ses
12 microns j'achète encore de fringues
pour envoyer encore en pays
gère double crise qu'est ce que c'est le
régime politique là bas le régime
socialiste
ça se passe comment ça se passe comme
les socialistes comme les socialistes
raisons peu
tout et pour l'état
et pour vous c'est important ça ou pas
tellement au mois - moi tellement cette
fois c'est pas mon problème - la
politique
générale bonne la politique j'aime pas
si auto la politique j'ai grossi des
hommes politiques je les aime pas ça
c'est moins depuis que j'étais un petit
j'aime pas les hommes politiques
moi je suis j'aime les gens se font des
ddd des hommes d'affaires ou pour vos
jeux ballard c'est important le régime
politique
moi j'adore soupault surtout le
capitalisme a sauvé équilibre le faire
sur tout ce que vous de faire
voulait on peut vous donner vous pouvez
construire tout ce que vous voudrez mais
celui à les imiter toi essais contrôlés
a beaucoup web vous tous que
c'est qu'on dit n'est pas la politique
efficiente et respiratoires
oui c'est docteur liman dp paris je suis
là vers la tour eiffel
docteur liman cela veut dire c'est un
non combat conventionnel mais docteur
liman ça veut dire un mec qui s'habille
bien les docteurs de la sape je souhaite
via la sape
là je suis à paris j'ai contré partir au
pays au mois d'août pour faire un
magasin de fringues
il y aura toutes les marques daniel
hechter yves saint laurent nino cerruti
gianni versace
weston ventilo valentino au monde tout
ce que vous voudrez
bon
je n'ai rien à vous dire je m'attendais
c'est moi au mois d'août les 10 je suis
au pays je vais amener tout ce que vous
voulez quoi surtout de l'aca pas parce
que c'est mon domaine
docteur l'imac est riche c'est marcel
atroce
ça c'est du weston
place quant au lot mars et lassante chef
jacques ap chemise guy laroche
rabat nino cerruti
la veste
c'est yves saint-laurent
tâche était ça s'efface avec noblesse ça
c'est tremble avec élégance bon
c'est presque fini pour me représente
dieu ballard
djaballah ça veut dire de l'argent la
roseraie des billets de banque au match
aller c'est parce que il y avait le
pognon ainsi recruter et surtout connue
j'aime le sable je rentre au mois d'août
en vacances
pour le voir nos frères qui sont à
brazza et revoir toute ma famille qui
m'attaquent qui sortent ils attendent
de voir ce que j'ai laissé le magasin
d'habits la boîte
là je suis en
train de chaussures henri stoll
là je suis à langevin
et chantait de la plus jeune âge arrive
il se lance sans oublier 500 grammes de
bijoux sûrement
qu'il a vu à vous dire
[Musique]